hi folks
my name is pan and i'm from the
computational biology group microsoft
research asia
our group has been actively working on
cross-disciplinary projects of computer
science and fundamental biomedicine
research
recently we are exploring the
application of deep learning algorithms
on gene regulation modeling
and in this talk i will share with you
our recent thoughts and plans on this
direction
genes are made of dna
in our bodies
dna forms double-stranded helix that
stores the instructions for constructing
and operating a living organism
it defines the fundamental differences
between human and other creatures
marks our promise to certain diseases
and guides the synthesis of proteins
which are the macromolecules carrying
out all essential functions in our lives
so talking about something so important
how much do we know about it
you can say quite a bit
in 1950s
with the work of wilkins watson and
creek
we firstly saw the simple and elegant
structure of dna molecules
and learned how they were passed on
beautifully from parents to kids
and in early 2000s
was the progress of the human genome
project
we successfully mapped the complete
sequence of human genome dna
which is composed of more than three
billion nucleotides
most of the time
we thought we have correct the secret of
life
would be able to explain our appearance
and behavior differences
identify causes of diseases and develop
drugs to cure them
however
every time with time passing by
would learn that we were awfully wrong
if we see the dna sequence of human as a
book
the previous revolutionary scientific
discoveries
indeed have opened it
and presented its content to us
but this is definitely not the end to
the story
we have not understood the content yet
we knew very little about the language
it is written in
to say we completely understand a
language
we need to know its syntax morphology
and semantics
we need to be able to read words
sentences
instead of just alphabets
studies have shown that there's rich
high-level information in dna language
yet a lot of them is still far beyond
our scope of knowledge
for example
thinking about our development process
we have over trillions of cells in our
bodies
and they were all actually originated
from one single cell the fertilized egg
so almost all cells in our bodies
share exactly the same dna
however they have divergent functions
that enable us to think
talk eat and walk
how is this achieved
the process of development is actually
tightly regulated
though every one of us
has slightly different dna sequence
there is a conserved gene regulation
program
that is making sure in most cases the
fertilized egg can turn into a
functional body
after numerous cell divisions and
differentiations
of course mistakes can happen
the dysregulated process may lead to all
sorts of developmental defects and even
tumor
but talking about gene regulation
what is it
gene regulation is the process of
turning genes on and off
it is a well-programmed and sensitive
mechanism that ensures proper genes
expressing proper amount of product at
proper time
it is not only the basis for the
development of multicellular organisms
but allows all type of creatures to
respond to environmental stimuli
promptly
for example
our immune cells can be activated upon
pathogen infection
and start attacking the invaders very
rapidly
due to their specialized gene regulation
programs
in other words
gene regulation programs tell our bodies
how to read the dna sequence correctly
at that very moment to carry out correct
functions
in-depth research on specific genes have
shed light on the pattern of gene
regulation during development
and allowed us to fix a handful of
problems caused by certain
dysregulations
however
there are over 20 000 genes and at least
10 times more candidate gene regulators
driven by different mechanisms on our
genome dna
their interactions can be complicated on
both temporal and spatial skills
they form dynamic regulatory networks
and it might be impossible for us to
understand the general mechanism of gene
regulation
was traditional biological research
approaches
if we'd like to see the whole picture of
gene regulation
we need a fundamental breakthrough on
the methodologies
how does experimental approaches can
help us
one straightforward idea is to observe
how gene regulation works directly with
the microscope
the development of microscopy technology
has allowed many progresses on
fundamental biology in the past decades
however the diameter of dna helix is
only 2 nanometers
and gene regulation is an environmental
dependent dynamic process
we can hardly see how gene regulation
happens directly inside the crowded
cells filled with numerous tiny
molecules with current microscopy
techniques
another candidate is deep sequencing
will it bring us another miracle as it
did for human genome project
to some extent yes
veriz deep sequencing techniques
generated a gigantic amount of data
and from which
we took a glimpse of gene regulation
patterns
or we can say the principles how cells
interpret dna languages
such as
oh there must be a verb in a sentence
but there are also a lot of limitations
aside from the technical limitations one
crucial question is
do we really know what we are looking
for in the data
can we understand
what we saw
from the data
we humans invented and evolved the
language we used for daily communication
but the language of dna and the gene
regulation
is a different story
what if the answer just lies in the data
but we cannot see it
luckily we now have a powerful helper
artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence has been doing
an excellent job on interpreting human
verbal and visual languages
it should possess the ability to
interpret dna language as well
while many researchers also believe in
the idea and have been making great
progress towards this direction
for example
some of them have been focusing on the
3d structure of genome
despite the nanoscopic diameter of dna
the length of our genome is astonishing
it's two meters long
to fit into the tiny cell nucleus at the
scale of micrometers
dna is carefully folded
and packed into a 3d structure
biological experiments have indicated
that the 3d structure of dna is often
stable and conservative
also it plays important roles in gene
regulation
it is like a backbone
guiding the orchestra of dynamic and
subtle regulation events
in isolated compartments
or we can say
it actually defines the syntax of gene
regulation
however
the pattern how a given dn sequence
folds remains unclear
so far experimental methods still suffer
a limitation of resolution
while the best methods can provide us a
genome contact map
at killer base pair resolution
most regulation events happen at a scale
around 10 bases
thus people have turned to deep learning
models
last year nature methods published a
study of three dna structured prediction
was convolutional neural network
the trend network did not only capture
the known folding features
but also reviewed many new patterns that
were later validated by biological
experiments
which brought us more insights about the
dna folding principles
this is a great achievement
however
compared to the syntax
semantics might be more important for us
to understand a language
while the structure can imply gene
regulation pattern
it will not tell us what exactly is
happening
we still need to learn the semantics
from the perspective of semantics many
have focused on
cis-regulatory elements prediction and
cyst regulation modeling
cis regulatory elements are non-coding
dnas that regulate the expression of
their neighboring genes
cys regulation is a vital mechanism of
gene regulation
especially during early development
for example
it has been long known that
a point mutation
in a cis regulatory element named zrs
leads to polydactyly a kind of lymph
malformation in humans and other
creatures
also not surprisingly
the activity of cis regulatory elements
vary by context
thus allowing different gene regulation
in different cell types
with growing efforts
many more cis regulatory elements have
been identified by experiments
in the past 20 years
however confusions came along
cis regulatory elements with new
features kept emerging
and the definition of these elements
became broader and bigger
currently
people tend to identify candidate 6
regulatory elements with a combination
of dna sequence
and their epigenetic features
i'm not going into the details of
epigenetic features here though they are
actually important concepts
briefly speaking epigenetic features are
chemical modifications on dna and dna
binding proteins
they can change the properties of dnase
without altering the sequences
they made it dna more versatile
like declension in linguistics
by versatile actually i mean it
for example in latin
the pronominal adjective annie
can decline to more than 10 forms in
different scenarios
which is already disturbing
however
epigenetic modifications on dna
can have more variations
some of them indicate the activation of
the gene
others may indicate the repression
and some may mark the developmental
related genes
but for many of them we still haven't
figured out their functions yet
thus
understanding how different epigenetic
features affect cis regulatory elements
and the gene regulation
has become an outstanding task
though many studies have attempted to
interpret this regulation with
computational methods
most often focused on classic machine
learning methods
which were not able to learn and embed
different levels of simatic information
in the language of dna
as the consequence
the manual work achieved good
performance on given data sets in given
cell types
they showed limited ability of
generalization
this is a huge drawback
if we'd like to learn gene regulation in
development of early embryos
a big problem lying ahead is the lack of
data
due to both technical and ethnic ethical
issues to bypass the data problem
we need to review the general principles
of gene regulation
and know how to interpret interpret the
language of data of dna
we're expecting the more sophisticated
deep learning algorithms contributing to
the situation
adapting rapidly evolving algorithms in
natural language processing
transfer learning and etc
we are building a multi-level simatic
aware model
that aims to learn the general
principles of cyst regulation across
cell types
though details may not be disclosed at
this moment
more are expected to be shared in the
next few months
cyst regulation is only one of the many
mechanisms cells adapt for gene
regulation
keeping the tiny machine running is a
delicate
process the rules behind it have to be
carefully designed and precisely
executed
revealing these principles won't only
enlighten us how life works
but may also offer us opportunities to
understand why it feels
so we can prevent or cure disease better
and stay healthy
we hope our work can bring a more
systematic perspective for computational
genomics
and inspire more research towards
deciphering the underlying mechanism of
gene regulation in cells
thanks for your attention